تضم مدينه باترسون ثاني اكبر تجمع للعربي
على مستوى الولايات المتحده نسبتهم تقل عن
15% من سكانها لكن اسهامهم اكبر بكثيرا في
الاقتصاد ومجالات الحياه الاخرى وقد اوصل
نشاطهم سياسي عضوا عربيا الى مجلسها
البلدي واول عمده للمدينه من اصل عربي لكن
هناك قلق هذه المره بشان مشاركه في
الانتخابات النصفيه اذا نسبه المشاركه في
هذه الانتخابات مساله تقلقنا كثيرا لا
سيما في ضواحي باترسون حيث نحتاج الى
تحفيز الناس للخروج والتصويت خصوصا مع
ارتفاع اسعار الوقود
تحفيز الناقبين العرب هدف الجمهوري ايضا
عبر محاوله استماتهم بقضيتي الاقتصادي
والقيم الاجتماعيه المحافظه التي يتمسك
بها اغلبهم وفي ضوئها يصبح التصويت
للديمقراطيين نفاقا كما يرى هذا الناشط
الجمهوري الذي يتوقعوا عوده العرب الى
التصويت لحزبه مجددا
كمان بالاجهاض لما تقتل انت نفس مثلا
بالطريقه هذه فانت كيف مثلا بتناقض بنفسك
لما تكون انت بتامن مثلا اشي معين وبتروح
انت بتايد حزب بيساوي هذا الموضوع وانا مع
الحزب الجمهوري لاني انا هذا اللي حفظت
عليه من اللي هو بامن بالعيله بالبلد
وبالله
التدين والمحافظه ليس حكرا على الجمهوريين
فهناك ديمقراطيون محافظون اجتماعيا
والمعيار في التصويت كما يرى هذا الامام
يجب ان يكون برنامج المرشحين ذاته نحن همم
في اعتقادي لسندراطيين ولا جمهوريين احنا
مع القيم مع المبادئ مع الاخلاق التي تخدم
الاسره وتخدم قضايانا يستقطب الحزب
الديمقراطي كثيرا من العرب الامريكيين
بخطابه المدافع عن الحقوق المدنيه وقضايا
الهجره ولقليا وقد دفعت سياسات اداره
ترامب السابقه كثيرا منهم نحو الجناح
التقدميه لساري
عربيه يعني فاتح ابوابه
بشكل كبير
الجمهوري المناطق اللي هو قوي فيها بتطلع
على يعني مغلقه في وجه العرب
طريقه فلسطين هو الاسم الجديد للشارع
الرئيسي في مدينه باترسون او رام الله
الصغرى كما يسميها البعض ولان فلسطين هي
البوصله لكثيرين يتجه العرب الامريكيون
اكثر رغم ميلهم للمحافظه في القيم
الاجتماعيه نحو اليسار التقدمين الذي يبدو
اكثر توازنا تجاهها قضايا الشرق الاوسط
وعلى راسها القضيه الفلسطينيه